وكان رئيس الاوكراني قد قال ان الوضع في
المناطق الرئيسيه لجبهه دومباز شرقيه
اوكرانيا لا يزال صعبا للغايه لكنه قوتك
ياذ تصد الهجمات الروسيه واكد زنسكي في
خطاب له ان القوه الروسيه دمرت بالكامل
مدينه بخموت احدى اكثر المناطق اشتعالا في
الجبهه
صعبه
وحولها الجيش الروسي الى انقاذ المحترقه
اشكر جميع ابطالنا كل الجنود والقاده
الذين يسيطرون على الجبهه في هذه المناطق
ويصدون الهجمات ويلحقون خسائر ملحوظه
بالعدو ردا على الجحيم الذي دخل اوكرانيا
تحت العالم الروسي
بيراميدزنسكي ان صيغه بلاده للسلام تشمل
10 نقاط من بينها الامن النووي واستعاده
وحده الاراضي الاوكرانيه كما ذكر زنسكي ان
النقاط ال 10 تشمل ايضا امن الطاقه وعوده
جميع اسرى الحرب والمبعدين المحتجزين على
اراضي روسيا واضاف ان احدى المهام
الرئيسيه لاوكرانيا هي اشراق العالم في
تنفيذ ملموس لنقاط معادله السلام كما شدد
على ضروره ضماني مساله ما وصفها بالدوله
الارهابيه عن هذه الحرب